yeah for you though like it's crazy
because with all your success right you
have like you you see a guy like DJ
Khaled who's put out like these gigantic
anthems meanwhile you have like you have
gems you got like dope records like you
got plaques as a DJ but you also as to
where like maybe we the best didn't
necessarily work out too crazy on the
artist side you got generation now which
is like
man [__] kudos to you guys
um
why do you think like you never really
reached the heights as a solo DJ and
because there was a point in time where
you wanted Atlantic and then you ended
up at Koch right and you had some really
you won by then or E1 but you had some
like really big records that maybe just
weren't like
I feel like were slept on or didn't like
pop in the way that maybe I thought they
should have like why do you think that
is
um
I don't know that's a good question I
mean are you saying in comparison to
Khalid or just in my own just in in your
like like I feel like you had records
that could have been [__] number one
records yeah you know I mean I you know
I definitely had some records that
chartered that did amazing for me My
Moment was one of them wishing was
another one that was a big record yeah
it was hard you know I mean at at that
space or point in my career you know I'm
kind of like in comparison like
I'm more of a reserve type of person
like obviously Khalid is a very he's a
personality he's a very big personality
Superstar personality you know what I'm
saying and that and that that took him
to like amazing Heights and you know I
tip my hat off to him kudos to like all
his success but you know like for me
like there was just
my my route and you know how I attacked
the game was a little it was it was over
here you know but but I think that was
dope about it is that you know there's a
there's like obviously
there's room and there's space for both
of us to be these these dominant figures
and like go-to people that and can
Inspire other DJs 100 you know want to
be the next Cali or drink yeah you guys
are like the the bar for sure you know
and like for me it was like you know
even outside of just my records it was
like all right I'm still putting out
tapes that are classics through those
years like whether it was Fab or whether
it was oh the Fab [__] was so good
there's no kind of Dream Chasers you
know I got Childish Gambino tape like
Jeremiah tape like you know I was even
even during that time you know I did
little babies tape like you know I got
some [__] so there was forgot about the
Childish Gambino [__] there was a lot of
[__] that I was I was doing I was you
know building Mean Street Studios which
became like a hub for you know
everything that was going on in the
culture in Atlanta when we were doing
with generation now like cultivating
uzi's career and Jack's career like you
know I just I wore a lot of hats so
you know for me it was like this is my
Lane you know I'm not trying to be
anybody else right you know what I'm
saying like this is DJ Drama and this is
how I approach and attack the game and
you know what I mean it was like Hey I'm
gonna go for what's mine you know I'm
gonna make a name for myself and and be
you know the greatest and you know go
down in history is arguably one of if
not the greatest DJ of all time